this is DW news Africa coming up on the
program Queen Elizabeth has died after
70 years on the throne
how will she be remembered across Africa
like a shock and bereaved I follow her
since I was a child
so I must say it's very sad news she's
lived a very
historic tremendous life and I hope she
can rest in peace
the Queen's story cannot be told without
Africa we look at the relationships he
had with many African countries
also coming up the raw impact of climate
change on Africa and the failure of the
West in showing their commitment African
leaders lashed out at industrialized
nations for not showing up at a summit
in the Dutch city of Rotterdam it was
dedicated to helping African nations
adapt to the impact of climate change
I think that as we made the effort to
leave Africa and come to Rotterdam it
would have been easier for the Europeans
and the others to also be here after all
they're the main polluters of the planet
who's not at the table matters and I
think that's where the struggle is is
that we need to continue to see this as
an existential threat for everyone and
not for just one side of the world
foreign
[Music]
ER and you are welcome to the program it
is the end of an era Queen Elizabeth
died after his 70-year Reign tributes
have been pouring in from all over the
world we'll take a look at the Queen's
relationship with Africa and what kind
of Legacy she leaves but first let's
hear how people across the continent
will remember here
who miss her calm demeanor her
leadership as one of the few women
leaders in the world
and also her contribution to Global
Peace and development I remember I asked
the woman figure
who is one of the women who made the
whole world proud in this patriarca
world yeah and during her win Ghana and
most of African countries were still
under colonialism and we thought at a
point she would have apologized to US
based on what her people did to us but
she didn't and all in all we still have
a peaceful relationship with her we wish
her farewell and may her soul rest in
perfect peace
she always wanted the world to be to be
in peace even though she's limited to
how much influence she could have at the
time but I think she tried her best I
mean nobody is perfect but she she tried
her best so I think in Africa we have a
lot of respect for her I think they have
to bring back all our jewelry and
enough that are in the ground
they have to bring
from Africa she was 96 years old so it's
to be expected she's lived a very
historic tremendous life and I hope she
can rest in peace I don't think the
death of
death of I am
teach and I'm Kenyan it doesn't affect
me that much
clearly mixed reactions there but one
thing is for sure the story of the queen
cannot be told without looking at a
relationship she had with many African
countries here's why
Queen Elizabeth had a special
relationship with Africa
she turned 21 on a visit to South Africa
and she was in Kenya when she heard that
her father King George VI had died
the Grievous news of her father's death
reached the young Queen now age 25 at
this Lodge in the highlands of East
Africa
she returned home for her coronation
the Archbishop lowers the five-pound
symbol of Might and power and as he
places it upon the Queen's head and
removes his hands the assemblage in one
voice cries
God Save the Queen
return to Africa
Africa Zimbabwe then Rhodesia in 1965.
prior to that in 1956 the queen had been
in Nigeria
in 1961 she made her first trip to Ghana
Elizabeth toured Uganda in 1954 and in
2007.
she also visited Ethiopia
but not the more recent Commonwealth
members
Rwanda Gabon Togo or Cameroon
over the decades the queen met most of
Africa's notable leaders
including Nelson Mandela
Julius
and Ellen Johnson sirleaf
[Applause]
trees places institutions and streets
carried Queen Elizabeth's name for many
decades
well the queen also touched many lives
we spoke to one woman in Ghana who met
her in person when receiving the young
leaders award an award for young people
across the Commonwealth who dedicate
their lives to serve the communities in
unique ways Amina Bawa shares her
memories of the queen with us
the news of her person is
so devastating but again an opportunity
for us to reminisce and celebrate her
long-lasting Legacy
her unmatched humility
dignity and values of of service will
continue to live in me especially and
the lives of the young people she
inspired
the one-on-one posture in the award
presentation is one that reminds me of
how my grandmother was giving me the
last person in the house just to
persuade me to go to school
I was actually shedding tears while
receiving the award from her
the moment of touching her hand is one
that made me feel I had received some
new Breath of Life
okay so once in a lifetime experience
that I will forever cherish
um so my thoughts of sympathy are with
the royal family and the English people
may have beautiful soul be blessed now
we've invited masharia munene historian
professor and foreign policy expert at
the United States International
University Africa based in Nairobi Kenya
hello and welcome to the program sir now
we've been hearing some mixed reactions
from across the continent what kind of
Legacy do you think the queen leaves
behind in Africa
the continuity of British presence as
the head of the Commonwealth in which
many of the former British colonies are
members by choice and she was that
symbol so and very personable person and
people liked her but the Commonwealth is
the main Legacy that she lives but very
positive the other part being the
colonial
part as the Monarch during colonial
period was the last the last decade of
colonialism may not be very pleasant but
the transition from colonialism to
Independence and then involved in the
con in the Commonwealth goes to her he
gives us some credit
um I mean you touched a bit on that
because yes in a way she represented a
country that colonized parts of Africa
but what role did she play in Africa's
fight for independence from British
colonial rule
well she did not play a role in the
struggle for Independence she was a
respect recipient of the struggle itself
the good thing about her is that she
took it in stride of course the Prime
Minister the minister the ones who dealt
with the issue and the father she became
a queen when she was in Kenya watching
some animals gives it gives a little bit
of um uh relevance to particular to
Kenyans and to other people but she did
not play as far as I know a role in the
decolonization she was a recipient of
the struggle against colonialism and she
took it very well I definitely
um well put on your side but some say
she wasn't really in a position to it
just after she started her rule she as
one would describe say what's open to
the idea of it happening
yeah I think she was open to the idea
being a young lady who's just um trying
to enjoy herself and then something
happens it was um
very good of that to adjust to the
realities of the time and I think her
handling of the common was the evolving
Commonwealth
it gives them some respect but she
seemed to blend very well with a new
independent countries and make them feel
that they are welcome in the common room
was a part of it so they she made them
feel good and acceptable which was a
credit to her and for that reason she's
fairly popular you know in fact the
common was expanded when she was there
so we had countries like Mozambique and
Rwanda join although they never were
British colonies because of the way it
appeared to be good
um you mentioned earlier how frequently
she was visiting the continent Kenya is
is one of the countries that she was at
particularly when she heard of the uh
the news of the death of her father how
would you describe her overall personal
relationship with the African continent
[Music]
she was a symbol of a system that was
not very good during colonial things but
as a person I don't think people took um
anger
they just saw as a symbol of a system
that was not very good and since the
people also understand that the people
who runs the country is really the Prime
Minister and the ministers and she's
just symbolic over long-lasting system
uh of the British imperialism and as the
heads the titular head was she just
looked good to the point that some other
people sometimes to emulate her because
she looked good but there is no
animosity towards her as a person
okay not her as a person but the system
that she was part of but uh Professor
macharia munene historian and foreign
policy expert in Nairobi Kenya thank you
for your insights
thank you very much